I had a theory a few months ago that
this is not mikola inside the Cocoon
this was a far-stretch theory that
didn't hold a ton of ground his size
here in mowgun's Palace compared to the
intro cut scene was enough to make me
question its legitimacy I was also in
the mindset at the time that made me
question almost everything any character
in the game said for example Moog
referring to this being mikola inside
the Cocoon dearest Nicola
trust anything I was told and this
mindset was formed by my Relentless
efforts to try and understand every
deeper meaning in Elden Ring's story and
how they were all connected this
obviously led me down a path of
frustration that resulted in me having
to take a step back from the game for a
while and this was the best thing I
could have done it changed my
perspective and mindset that just gave
me a whole new appreciation for the
game's lore and story now do I still
believe this isn't mikola inside the
Cocoon no I do think it's him however I
do believe I was on the right track
whoever Michela was his intentions his
beliefs his dreams I don't believe those
exist anymore while he may be physically
here endlessly asleep inside this cocoon
I believe he's changed defeated in his
previous Pursuits and has potentially
submitted himself to Moog the reasons
we'll discuss today make sure to
subscribe all that good YouTube stuff
we're getting really close to a hundred
thousand subscribers I don't know if we
can hit that by the end of the year but
we can certainly try I'd appreciate it
if you did and with all that said let's
talk about nikola's dream
a delicate water lily of unalloyed gold
that has started to fade and Wilt a
flower signifying faith in the halog
tree thought to be beloved by the
empyrean Mikala in his youth Nicholas
rare lily can be used to craft
bewitching branches which are used to
turn enemies into temporary allies its
description reads the imperian mikola is
loved by many people indeed he has
learned very well how to compel such
affection both descriptions of Nikolas
Lily and the bewitching branch bring up
some questions for me if Nicholas Lily
is meant to signify faith in the halog
tree why does it phrase it as this was
something that was once thought to be
beloved by mikola has his faith faded
and wilted away similar to that of the
Lily itself if michalo was loved by so
many people why does it mention that
Nikola had to learn how to compel people
with such affection if he was truly
loved would he really need to learn the
skill of doing so this all seems
especially suspect from the description
of an item that can Bewitched the mind
of those it is used on most descriptions
we can find in the game speak to
mikola's Charisma and his ability to
influence those around him including his
own twin sister Melania whose winged
Helm description includes a quote from
her that says my brother will keep his
promise he possesses the wisdom the
Allure of a God he is the most fearsome
imperian of all I find the use of the
word fearsome to be sort of strange here
again if he was truly loved by most in
the lands between he wouldn't really
need to influence out of fear at least
in my eyes it contradicts other
descriptions about mikola that puts him
in a different light but what is This
Promise he made to his sister and what
kind of Promise would require him to
possess the wisdom of a god this is
something that has already been widely
discussed throughout the Alden ring
Community This Promise is most likely to
cure Melania of her burden to rid her
body of the Scarlet rot that has
Afflicted her since birth this is one of
the reasons the Haley tree exists once
mikola found that the urge tree couldn't
cure his sister he abandoned the golden
order fundamentalism and started
something completely new this is said to
be the start of unalloid gold and
Nicholas halictree a chosen land awaits
us albinorex The Medallion is the key
that leads to the city
which only acquaint treasure for we who
cannot make the journey
would you consider doing me a great
service I must go back there is
something I must do
even if I must say farewell to my wolf
lover will you show me the way
to the land of Nicola's halik tree
The Healing Tree is the chosen land for
the Alban norks that Albus was referring
to Gideon ordered the slaughter of all
these people and mikola offered them
some kind of Refuge from the horrors
that awaited their race this place
obviously needed to be hidden from those
who would seek to take advantage of it
so a secret Medallion entrance and the
lighting of four Nicholas statues
guarded by skilled almanorics is
required to gain entrance to the Haley
tree but what is the halog tree what is
unalloid gold here's how I've come to
understand it in the most simple way
unalloid means pure and unalike gold is
to the halic tree as the golden order is
to the herd tree I see it as its own
order opposite to that of the golden
order that mikola decided to abandon
we've discussed in many different videos
that the ERD tree and the golden order
are corrupted and seek to manipulate
people into believing in its power I'm
sure Nicholas saw this as well and
wanted to start thing that was pure and
free from corruption this is unalloid
gold we can go deeper and over
complicate this of course but once I
decided to try and simplify my
understanding of eldenring the easier it
became to truly understand it the Haley
tree Knight armor has its left breast
emblazoned with the crest of the Haley
tree and reads as though watered with
mikla's own blood since it was a sapling
the halic tree ultimately failed to grow
into an ERD tree so the way we can look
at the Halo tree at this point in the
timeline when we come back to the lands
between and play the game we can see it
as a failure the halog tree did not work
for the purpose it was created for now
it is possible that it didn't work
because moogs stopped its process before
it was complete I think it's clear that
while mikola created the halog tree to
cure his sister it was also used to help
mikola grow into adulthood since his own
burden was being cursed with eternal
youth he is inside a cocoon after all
all likely to change his appearance from
a child into something more so he was
trying to kill two birds with one stone
here is sister of the Scarlet rot using
his own blood to water the halog tree
and create unalloid gold which Melania
uses to subside the Scarlet rod and grow
himself into adulthood while inside the
Cocoon however Moog removed mikola from
the halog tree before any of these
things could reach full completion the
Halo tree looks like it's been rotting
away for some time and mikola's body
looks more like a dying Omen than
anything else if we look at the opening
cinematic in this painting depicting
Moog carrying who we believe to be
mikola we can see Mo carrying the cocoon
in the background and mikola looking
much different than he does when we find
him in moguin's Palace Moog is clearly
using mikola's imperian blood properties
with a formless mother to create a new
Dynasty or they refer to it as Dynasty
does anyone know why they say Dynasty
instead of Dynasty I find that very
confusing but maybe mikola couldn't grow
inside the halog tree just from his own
blood and cure melania's Rod maybe
placing himself inside the Cocoon didn't
allow him to grow into adulthood he
tried with the ERD tree and the golden
order he tried with his own halog tree
and unalloyed gold but nothing seemed to
work fully to achieve the ultimate goal
to rid him and his sister of their
burdens they've had since birth I think
it's entirely possible that mikalo ran
out of options and gave himself to his
half-brother Moog to at least change his
body into something other than a child
with the possibility of moog's God the
formless mother to change the properties
of mikola's blood to potentially give
the blood the ability to create flames
and burn away any burdens the body May
hold I see this process as being
extremely painful this could be where
they sleeping properties of Saint Trina
who is widely discussed to also be
mikola started from for him to be able
to just sleep through this process to
somehow bear the pain and torture that
comes with it sort of like anesthesia
but I think we'll have to talk about
this in another video the saint Trina
Laura runs very deep so keep on the
lookout for that this is all a major
stretch I understand that there isn't
much we understand about mikola at this
point if he did do all of this that I'm
suggesting then he didn't let anyone in
the halog tree know of his plan and he
definitely didn't let Melania know what
he was doing either he went on a rampage
through the lands between defying mikola
which ultimately ended in a stalemate
between her and radon and yes I say it
was a stalemate she had to be carried
back to the Haley Tree by one of her
Knights after she nuked the continent of
Khalid and even then she couldn't kill
radon and yet she still refers to
herself as undefeated which I guess is
technically true if you discount a tie
in there there is a lot of holes in this
Theory but I think it's fun to think of
different intentions with the demigods
and especially mikola since we know so
little about him but I think it's clear
that mikola had a dream to help those
burdened in the world whether they were
his own family or not but what he's
become when we find him here in mowgun's
Palace I have to believe is a far
stretch from what he was before just
like most things throughout the lands
between this is what I meant when I said
that this mikola is not the same mikola
from all the descriptions and stories we
read about him I think when we do meet
him in a future DLC we won't be met with
an imperial child who seeks to help us I
believe we'll meet a broken Orchard Soul
who went above and beyond to achieve his
dream and I'm sure he won't be
particularly happy to know that we
killed his sister that he went through
all of this to try and save especially
after everything he's been through and
the changes that he's undergone but all
I know is that it's going to be a sight
to see and I can't wait to see it
[Music]
[Music]